okay for the drop thank you
hey it's Brady Herod's birthday by way
of wishing them a happy birthday I made
him a cake so let's give them a quarter
of this cake just to say oh you know
let's divide this up it's a square it's
a square eight inches on a side give or
take let's divide it up and put a few
sprinkles over here
there you go Brady out put a candle
right in the middle where's my candle
what I do with a candle let's cut it
right along here along here I made sure
that this is halfway along there and
over there yep we got a quarter of this
out of here okay now I've got a cake oh
it's a square cake missing one corner my
wife's coming home I've got two kids
coming home in me how can I divide this
remaining part of the cake into four
equal parts that will make both of my
kids my wife and me happy look easy to
do it in three parts 1 2 right 1 part 2
part 3 parts
how do you divide this up into 4 equal
parts
I told you know what can happen I warned
you my wife's gonna kill me good reason
didn't just warn make it habit this is
twice so I'm an idiot
oh my yeah how did the fine get to Keiko
it burn its way through here and you can
see the cocoa itself is burning
what shape is listen it's sort of an
l-shape what if I reduce that L and
repeat repeat it like this and then a
cut here cut here I've now got four
pieces that are nominally the same one L
shaped here one L shaped here one L
shape here and then one over here
they're all the same size and if you
think about it we can use recursion to
do the same thing for Brady's piece
whole cake with the whole cake was for
Brady got one full unit I get
three-quarters of unit my wife gets
three quarters of unit one kid gets
three quarters of unit the other kid
gets three quarters of a unit and it's
all right
because Brady got the biggest piece I've
already had a little bit clearer already
been eating it the cocoa itself is
burning I warned you I said I'm okay you
just more than just were me yeah so how
do I get rid of this geez ha it sounds
later it's not going to be like a bomb
or something is it cuz it's all like
packed in oh yes good exploding cocoa
has been this huge problem across the
agency